here now with reaction Fox News
contributor Ari Fleer the Harris poll
chairman Mark Penn along with pollster
Lee Carter you know Ari I began
specifically with those pieces from The
Washington Post in Politico they have a
lot of sources and Democrat circles this
is based on at least
42 Democrat sources there's a lot of
angst you know this we're both former
press secretaries you don't want these
pieces landing on your
desk no and let talk about one of my
favorite things in that Washington Post
article was Democrats at the White House
saying they want them to walk less so
the PE public doesn't see him have
difficulty walking so what's the most
concrete thing they've done they have
stopped him from walking up the big
Majestic steps to the top of Air Force
One and he goes in the baby steps on the
bottom but Kaylee as you know once you
enter the bottom level of Air Force One
there's no elevator there's nothing that
gets you to the higher levels making it
easier there's an inner staircase so the
only thing they're doing is hiding Joe
Biden there is no reason to have him
take those lower steps nothing is easier
for him he still has to climb but it's
the only way they can hide him and
that's unfortunately the reality of what
you have to deal with when you're
dealing with an 81y old they are hiding
the president so the country cannot see
the difficulties he has that's a shame
that is not what you do with a president
it's it's basement campaign 2.0 except
this time it's the Oval Office you know
Mark in one of these pieces Ron Clan was
asked at one of these Swanky events that
both parties have he was asked you know
what's the backup plan to which he
replied there is no backup plan that
seems inconceivable to me given the
polling given the president's age do you
think there's a backup
plan when your age is twice your
approval rating that is a problem no
question about it but but I don't think
that there is going to be a change here
in the nominee in that NBC poll 77% of
Democrats picked Biden for the nominee
he's got the full party Machinery he
wants to run again he is running so I
don't think there's a plan B Biden has a
year I've worked with presidents before
so is Ari a year was a long time in
presidential history and let's face it
if people thought the economy was going
well they wouldn't care about his age
it's really about the economy
immigration crime and key issues he's
got a year to fix yeah Year's a long
time Lee and I I mean you look at the
polls eight National polls have Trump
beating Biden that's got to cause
trepidation among Democrats but among
Republicans polls haven't always
translated to electoral victories I
think of the Red Wave for instance so
where are
we when you look at what happened with
the Red Wave there was there was
something else that was going on there
though because a lot of people were
saying that the economy was the number
one concern but really there was also
abortion on the ballot and a lot of
women's issues that hurt uh Democrats it
I hurt Republicans in addition there
were a lot of weak candidates um on the
Republican ticket so this is a very
different situation because you're
looking at polling that says this is
Trump versus Biden not just generic
ballot Just this is exactly what people
are looking at it does not look good uh
for Joe Biden right now and there's a
couple of things that I would be most
concerned about if I were him number one
he is losing significant numbers among
younger voters he carried young voters
by a lot uh last time it doesn't look
like he's going to be able to do that
the other thing that is really damning
in some these polls is his favorability
among Independents two and three are
saying they look at him unfavorably 55%
I'm sorry 65% of even Democrats say they
don't think he's fit mentally fit for
office so these numbers are really
really staggering and he can't just get
through them by denying it um and he's
not going to be able to do it by hiding
either I mean to AR's point you can't
stop him from walking you can't stop him
from Talking he's got to get out there
and tell his story and and you know you
heard Yellen today say it's her job to
tell his story no it's not it's his job
he's got to get out there and convince
the American people he's up for the job
and right now it's not looking good all
right you know to that point you know I
I worked on a campaign you always know
the Achilles heel of your boss you know
their strengths you know their
weaknesses this is a huge weakness for
Biden his age how as a team do you
unwind that do you reverse the
conception the perception rather of the
American
people well there's only one way and
that's to turn him into benjam button
and watch him get younger and that's not
going to happen and so it really is a
huge problem for the Democrats and what
a massive opportunity for Republicans
whether the nominee is President Trump
or Nikki Haley or somebody else as I've
like to say and I've said it forever
don't don't compare Donald Trump to the
almighty compare him to the alternative
and the alternative is Joe Biden I I am
I'm just struck by how the Democrats are
create committing political suicide it
is beyond belief that they are putting
up the worst two candidates against
Donald Trump in the country there is
nobody who is lose easier to Donald
Trump than Joe Biden and KLA Harris yet
that is the path that Democrats are on
it's inexplicable and that's why I think
you're going to see huge pressure built
around Joe Biden to get him to drop out
right before the convention I think that
pressure is going to build Mark you know
in the wake of the 2023 elections not a
good night for Republicans yet again not
not a good night in 2022 for Republicans
but in the wake of that election
Politico said there there are two camps
of Democrats there's the time to freak
out Democrats because they see the
weakness of Joe Biden and there's the
time to chill out Democrats because they
keep doing well in elections which Camp
are you chill out or freak
out I've been in the freakout camp for a
long time I've been calling attention to
these same numbers I mean Trump has been
ahead in in the Harris pulse for months
uh Biden's been in this kind of doldrums
particularly I thought he had a very bad
summer uh but I come back to you know
Biden like Trump in many ways has
managed to have nine lives time and time
again everybody thought he was out you
know last time in the Democratic primary
and suddenly he was in everybody thought
he was going to lose and he went and he
won so I do think you're going to see
Democrats hold on to that but the
reality is we've got to see economic
Improvement that's what this election is
really about not about age Lee one thing
that that Biden team has done well is
mobilize an army of influencers to reach
jenz to reach Millennials you mention
Trump is doing very well with this
cohort um unusually well for any
Republican but the day before the
midterms Biden brought all the Tik Tock
influencers into the oval and the days
before I should say with an aggregate
following of 67 million Obama met with
them they toured DC how powerful and how
difficult is that to combat this Army of
influencers that has a huge
megaphone be really hard to combat the
the army of influencers because they can
mobilize on key issues because some of
the polling that I've seen suggests that
seven and 10 Independent Women are going
to be driven to the polls this election
cycle because of abortion in three of
our key States uh abortion is going to
be on the ballot seven and 10
Independent Women nine in 10 Democratic
women and so if influencers are really
able to get out there and mobilize on
that issue I don't think they're going
to be able to mobilize on Joe Biden but
if they're going to be able to mobilize
on women's issues they could have a lot
of success and I think that Republicans
must come up with an answer that is an
all of the above answer that isn't just
to say they have to change their
position on abortion but what they do
need to do is change perceptions on how
they view women and so they need to come
up with a women's agenda that are going
to mobilize them just as much because
these influen are going to be hard to
beat especially on that particular issue
great Point Ari fer Mark pen Lee Carter
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else